Por qué se produce ahora este encuentro
después de años sin una reunión
bilateral
bueno Primero gracias por la invitación
esto hay que verlo dentro del contexto
de la administración de Richi sunak que
está intentando normalizar las
relaciones con con Europa
Richi es una que está tratando de
de darle un caris distintos a su
administración más allá de la de las
diferencias que había con Johnson y y la
administración del strust Entonces es el
contexto Esto no es aislado esto también
es parte de de del acuerdo de de Windsor
Entonces es una cuestión de intentar
normalizar las relaciones que tiene el
Reino Unido con Europa con el desafío
Eso sí de también tener que mantener
contento a los votantes más de derecha
que es el desafío que tiene actualmente
y le preguntó a grandes rasgos en que se
traducirán que ese materializarán esta
nueva cooperación entre París y Londres
Bueno hay acuerdos en términos de
seguridad hay acuerdos también en
términos de cooperación de energía pero
lo que ha llamado más la atención en
términos noticiosos en el Reino Unido es
el acuerdo concreto el anuncio que se
hizo de que el Reino Unido va a entregar
500 millones de libras esterlinas al
gobierno francés para construir un
centro de detención en el norte de
Francia cerca de de dunk ese ha sido el
principal anuncio que se ha recogido y
es lo que enfatizado también el gobierno
británico dentro de el Reino Unido dado
todas la la la la la la la la atención
noticiosa que ha recibido en el Reino
Unido el hecho de que han llegado más
refugiados a este país Yo diría que ese
es el principal anuncio lo que hay que
esperar es cómo va a ser recibido ese
anuncio dentro del Reino Unido si va a
ser visto como parte de
un fortalecimiento de las fronteras del
Reino Unido que es lo que los votantes
conservadores están pidiendo
si se está viendo como otra prueba más
de que el Reino Unido no tiene control
sobre sus fronteras y depende de otros
países para controlar la situación
quisiera recoger un par de cuestiones
que usted ha destacado por un lado la
importancia no de este nuevo centro de
atención en las costas francesas del
Canal de la Mancha que financiará en
gran parte el Reino Unido Y es que
precisamente tanto Emmanuel macron como
Richie sunak comparten esta digamos dura
retórica contra la migración clandestina
con el proyecto de ley que propuso el
partido conservador británico esta misma
semana que algunas organizaciones han
calificado de atentar incluso contra el
derecho internacional al asilo Pero
además
comparten un pasado una carrera en el
mundo de las finanzas le pregunto si
ambos mandatarios digamos comparten una
misma visión del mundo y esto facilita
el entendimiento entre ambos
en principio las relaciones parecen
tener como como tú bien dice una una
base común de hecho se habla acá en esta
tarde los medios británicos han hablado
de El bromance entre Richie sunak y
Manuel macrón precisamente por las
características que tú dices creo que si
bien
pueden tener y compartir una visión de
mundo con respecto a temas por ejemplo
con migración que tú dices eh sunat
tiene en este momento un desafío mucho
más grande
estaba mirando algunos comentarios en la
prensa británica y
algunos de los votantes conservadores no
están de acuerdo con lo que está
haciendo es una que sienten que debería
tener una retórica mucho más dura
todavía que ven que el acuerdo con con
Francia es un acuerdo blando y preferían
que incluso fuese mucho más extremo en
términos de retórica y acciones Entonces
es una básicamente están haciendo un
acto de equilibrio por un lado tratando
de normalizar las relaciones con Europa
Pero por otro lado tratando de mantener
contentos a posibles votantes que
teniendo en cuenta las elecciones
generales del próximo año